مشاهدينا افتتاح الاعمال المؤتمر في دورته
التاسعه والخمسين لمؤتمر ميونخ الدولي
الامن والذي ينتظر ان تتصدر مناقشته حرب
اوكرانيا اضافه الى ملفات كتغير المناخ
وازمه الطاقه وكذلك قضايا دوليه كبيره
اخرى كالعلاقه بين الغرب والصين المؤتمر
مشاهدينا في نسخته الحاليه لا تحضره روسيا
ولا ايران بسبب سلوكهما خلال السنه
الماضيه في حرب اوكرانيا وكذلك قامع
الاحتجاجات وزعزعه استقرار منطقه الشرق
الاوسط
ده مشاهدينا معكم في متابعه هذه الصور
المباشره من انطلاق مؤتمر ميونخ في دورته
التاسعه والخمسين للامن وبهذا المؤتمر كما
ذكرنا مشاهدينا ينعقد تزامنا مع مرور عام
على الحرب الاوكرانيه التي اندلعت في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير لعام 2022 بعد
ايام قليله من عقال دورته السابقه
اخبار الامن
اغرق العام الماضي وكان لدينا
امل
بان الرئيس
بوتن سيذهله التوحد المجتمع الدولي الذي
تمثله هنا في مؤتمر ميونخ الامني كلنا على
درايه ماء بما حدث
[موسيقى]
ارتكب انتهاكا للحضاره فهذه المره الاولى
منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه التي نرى فيها
في اوروبا دوله
تحرم حق الوجود
وبالتالي يشنوا عليها حرب متكامله
بعد عام من ذلك الوقت هنا كانه 40 14
مليون اوكراني شردوه
عشر الاف من الاطفال والنساء والرجال ممن
قتلوا
وجرحوا وعذبوا
واغتصبوا
وخطفوا كما ادعوكم
لان تلقوا نظره
على معرض جرائم الحرب الروسي الذي نعرضه
الان في الطابق الارضي
لكن اوكرانيا ليست بالمكان الوحيد الذي
يعاني فيها الشعب
وهناك
قائمه اخرى من الدول
رهنغارك ابدا
ودعوني اذكركم
بالتقرير
الخطير
لجنه حقوق الانسان
الامميه
التي قدمت حول
مصير المصير وهذه
الحروب ضد الانسانيه
والاعتداءات التي تمت
سنكرز هذا المساء في هذه الجلسه
الافتتاحيه
والجلسه الاولى
سنتحدث عن موضوع المحاسبه كيف
نحول دون
الحصانه وكيف
نعزز عمل المحكمه الدوليه وان يكون لدينا
محاكمات خاصه محكمه خاصه
لحالات الاعتداء هذه ان الصراعات التي
تحدثت عنها تبين ان ميثاق الامم المتحده
يتعرض لهجوم وانا الاعلان الدولي لحقوق
الانسان
ايضا هو تحت الهجوم ايضا نشهد في اوكرانيا
ليس مجرد معركه بين الشرق والغرب
وليس بين النيت وروسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي
لكنها معركه
بين سياده القانون
وقانون الغاب هذه
معركه تهتم لشانها العالم باكمله
وللحفاظ على هذا النظام العالمي نحن بحاجه
للمجتمع عبر الاطلسي
سنحتاج
للجنوب لذلك فان مؤتمر
ميونخ يضع هذا التسليط الضوء على هذا
الجنوب ويوم غد صباح الغد سنكرس
النقاش
للتحدث عن
الجنوب لنسخي لما يقلقهم ولدينا
[موسيقى]
عدد قياسي من منغوليا الى جمهوريه
الدومينيك من ناميبيا الى كولومبيا وغانا
والبرازيل اود ان نرحب كل
المندوبين هنا من امريكا اللاتينيه
وافريقيا واسيا
[تصفيق]
هذا المؤتمر يركز
على
حرب بوتين على اوكرانيا فلدينا رقم قياسي
للمندوبين من
الحكومه الاوكرانيه
والبرلمان الاوكراني
وكذلك من المجتمع المدني وكل
السعاده بان الرئيس سينضم الينا بعد قليل
اود ان ارحب
بالرجال والنساء اوكرانيا الشجعان
[تصفيق]
الدولي سيستخدم
سيستغل هذا المؤتمر للتنسيق
لتنسيق الدعم للاستقلال والحريه
والديمقراطيه
وكذلك
لكرامه اوكرانيا
وعندما ندعم الاوكران في حربهم من اجل
حريتهم فنحن نعلم انهم يحاربون من اجل
حريتهم وحريات اوروبا وحريه العالم كلي
سرور بان المستشار شورتس والرئيس ماكرون
سيكون اول
المتقدمين اليوم
اود ان ارحب بهذا الوجود الفرنسي الماني
كما سنناقش
التصميم الامني الاوروبيه وسعيد بان نرى
هناك مندوبين من مختلف ارجاء اوروبا
وانا ممتن
لحضوركم من مختلف
انحائي اوروبا كما اود ان ارحب
ممثلين المنظمات الدوليه من
اسره الامم المتحده
الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون الاقتصادي
وهي من المنظمات التي مازالت روسيا تشارك
فيها كما اننا سنصلط الضوء في هذا المؤتمر
وسنتخذ توجه
شموليا للامن سنتحدث عن عدم الامن
المناخيل
خطيئه التي يرتكبها بوتين هو هي انه هو في
وضع
ونحن علينا ان
نكرس مليارات كي ندعم اوكرانيا لشراء
السلاح للدفاع عن الديمقراطيه وسياده
القانون المال الذي سينفق بشكل افضل
لمساعده كل الاطراف للعمل
ولمحاربه اثار التغير المناخي وهو الخطر
الاكبر الذي نواجهه اود منكم ان
تنظروا الى او تراجع الكلمه التي تحدث
فيها يوم امس في جامعه ميونخ سنسلط الضوء
في هذا المؤتمر على دور المراه كما اننا
يسعدنا ان نعلن اننا كما وعدت العام
الماضي سيكون لدينا خمسين بالمئه
الامن في نسخته
هذا هذه الفعاليه التي ستستمر على مدار
ثلاثه ايام اليوم الجمعه وحتى التاسع عشر
من فبراير وسنكون معكم في متابعه لمجرات
هذا المؤتمر خلال هذه النشره والنشرات
المقبله ايضا